hey rob this is joe in memphis i have a
sports question for you
do you agree with me that uh tom brady
is a lizard person
i think there's uh some compelling
evidence i mostly go back to
uh well among other things he doesn't
age uh like a normal human being he's
won an inordinate amount of super bowl
rings but
my bigger thing is the clues given to us
by bill belichick
um bill belichick i believe is actually
a hero for our society he
um he i think in his own way is trying
to signal us
that uh that tom brady is a lizard
person
he's never uh bill belichick never looks
happy
even given all of the success he's had
he always looks like a grouch
he's uh i think if we were to watch any
of his press conferences
he would probably be blinking in morris
code watch out for tom brady he's a
lizard person so
i want to know where you fall and if so
if he is a lizard person should the
patriots in tampa baby stripped of all
their super bowl trophies
thanks again and i'll take my answer off
the air yeah thanks joe i've given a lot
of thought to this
um look as lizard people go
i think you know i think it's
it he ticks all the boxes brady
um as you say he's uh
he's he does not age he's he's a freak
of nature
it's very clear that bill belichick has
been giving press conferences
like prisoner of war videos for years um
in fact i always wanted to do my
interviews like bill belichick
and and i would have loved to have asked
belichick is brady a lizard person
because it would have been
um it could be i don't know and um just
thinking about kansas city next weekend
um i do i do like that brady is in the
pretty boy hall of fame
that's more important than being for me
a lizard person
is that he's a pr a very pretty man and
i have a
very soft spot in my heart for for
pretty men
and i i love to see him do well um
and if he is a lizard person um
you know it's made up for
by the fact that he is more importantly
extraordinarily pretty
thanks joe that was a good question